okay folks welcome back from the break
we're starting a few minutes early which
is sort of unusual at a conference you
usually start running behind even before
you start so this is the first panel and
the moderator is my friend and colleague
ester Fuchs we've been together at
Columbia for many many years and I'm
delighted to introduce her and she will
introduce the panel so Esther is a
professor of public affairs and
political science and she's director of
the urban policy program at Columbia
University she served the special
advisor to the mayor for government and
strategic planning and you heard that he
sometimes took her advice dr. Fuchs was
chair of the Urban Studies program at
Barnard and at Columbia College and
founding director of columbia university
center for urban research and policy she
currently serves on the new york city's
mayor sustainability advisory board the
New York City Economic Opportunity
Commission the New York City Workforce
Investment Board the New York City
Commission on women's issues she is
appointed to the committee on economic
inclusion of the FDIC and is on numerous
other boards dr. Fuchs is published
widely she is a frequent political
commentator in print and broadcast and
new media she received her BA from
Queens College at the City University of
New York and MA from Brown University
and a PhD in political science from the
University of Chicago it is my pleasure
to introduce my friend and colleague
ester Fuchs
just want to briefly welcome everybody
back to low library Columbia University
we're so delighted you're here this
morning and that you've stayed and
particularly welcome to all of our
international participants but a special
hello to all my students who are here
this morning as Michael Bloomberg told
us so eloquently we're here to share
knowledge what better place to share
knowledge than in a university and the
knowledge must be about how we
successfully educate our children in all
of our nation's all over the globe the
premise of this summit and of the global
partners program is that we can all
learn from each other that sounds very
simple but it's just so important
learning from each other at summits like
this will really protect and develop the
future well-being of all of our nation's
and our ability to educate our children
really if the greatest challenge of the
21st century so it's my pleasure and
really a great pleasure for me today to
introduce to you an extraordinary group
of world-class educators and our panel
is about reforming public education
systems all our panelists are from
global cities and they have their fair
share of challenges but they also have
some extraordinary successes and this
morning I hope after you listen you'll
have some serious questions for them
because they will be willing to answer
those questions this panel especially
will focus on some of the larger reforms
in these cities things that when we're
worrying about what goes on in the
classroom we don't always think about
but as Mayor Bloomberg said it's also
about how we structure our education
system which really empowers principals
and teachers fan
leaves and students to get it right in
the classroom what I'm going to do is
introduce each one of our panelists
separately they'll be speaking for about
10 to 12 minutes and then we'll take
questions at the end our first panelist
is Claudia Costin ms Costin is Secretary
of Education of Rio de Janeiro a
specialist in public policy education
and poverty alleviation and has
extensive academic and technical
experience and has served in many
management roles in governments and NGOs
in Brazil and in other nations some of
those roles have included federal
minister of state administration and
state reform secretary of planning and
evaluation of the ministry of finance
and she was also executive vice
president of the victor savita
foundation an organization devoted to
the improvement of the quality of public
education in Brazil miss Costin studied
public administration at guti i'm not
going to pronounce it right you know I
studied French in school what a mistake
yeah the de Vargas foundation in San
Paulo where she also obtained a master's
degree in economics and credits toward
her PhD in management she also teaches
at IBM ecs p department of economics
it's my pleasure to introduce to you the
Secretary of Education of Rio de Janeiro
Claudia Costin
good good morning everyone it's a
pleasure to be here thank you I'm
thankful for the kind invitation and I
want to compliment my the ester
professor ester folks my colleagues in
hooking mamta Agarwal and Johan are in
my ten minutes I it's very hard to
explain such an extensive reform as the
one we are doing in Rio but just to
quickly summarize we are in charge of
1064 schools 300 nursery schools and in
our system we work with nursery tto 9th
grade and the state is devoted to high
schools we have a very huge system that
has considered the biggest school system
municipal school system in the country
although we are not the biggest city and
we had lots of problems related to
social promotion and the effect and the
consequences that social promotion
brought to our schools just to give one
figure from our seven hundred thousand
kids 28,000 from fourth fifth and sixth
grades were illiterate they were in
sixth grade they were studying for a
long time and they were still illiterate
so we had the impression that many
problems were swept under the carpet not
learning def learning deficits and so on
so when we took off is when the mayor
took office and invited me it was
one year and 10 months ago we and after
a quick assessment of learning on how
schools were evolving Brazil has very
recently universalized the access to
elementary school education and then
quality was initially in all the cities
we decided to do it a diagnosed
diagnostic test and then take action and
one of the most challenging situations
that without width apart from the
general low quality was the fact that in
drug lord controlled areas and malisha
controlled areas we had a hundred and
fifty schools where learning was almost
impossible those schools were the only
presence of the state in those areas and
although a process of occupation and
pacification of those slums those
favelas was happening still it was
difficult for teachers to teach and kids
to learn so we developed a program
called schools of tomorrow while we were
reshaping the whole system in every
school in those schools we took
additional steps let me first explain
very quickly what we did in all the
schools we established a unified
curriculum that all schools had to
follow but it was organized on a by
Mastro basis so that teachers would know
exactly what was supposed to be teach in
each subject area in each grade y ou
remedial education was was being
provided for real fam attacking the kids
that were illiterate
accelerating the kids that were over age
we were organizing the curriculum by
monthly basis and training teachers to
be able to do that and so while
everything was going on that side of the
general approach which was a non excuse
approach but also very supportive
approach we this we took the schools of
tomorrow the schools in the drug
controlled areas and there we had we
established seven pillars first on those
areas school was all day long from 7 30
to 5 in the afternoon full-time
education with lots of arts sports and
school reinforcement for those kids
second we put in place science lab in
each classroom we took a very
experimental approach to teaching
science that would make kids want to go
to school every day because Co evasion
in these areas are is horrible so they
leave school to work for the drug lords
so we wanted them to love going to
school at the same time as we were
becoming more demanding with them we
decided also to train each teacher on
how to give classes that are more
dynamic and more prone to fight the blow
cognitive blockages that derive from
over exposure to violence we had
specialists that trained all our
teachers in this 150 school and also a
house program because in those areas
there are no health services so although
we
not afford to have health services in
every one of the 1064 schools at least
in those 151 schools we do have with
delivered health a health program also
not only treatment but also prevention
in those areas we have a huge problem
with with teenage pregnancies because
the girls feel that to be protected a
good shortcut would be to become
pregnant of an authority from the drug
the narco traffic so just we have also
established targets for every one of the
1,000 schools but if we achieve the
targets so we made schools accountable
for improving learning but if the school
achieve a target given go in those areas
they received an incremented bonus so
every school received bonus the team the
school team receive bonus if they
achieve the target but in those specific
150 schools the bonus is much higher
because teaching there is so challenging
we have already results to present in
one year and 10 months our index there
is an index that measure learning in
Brazil our index had reason in a very
impressive way and from the 290 schools
that achieved their target that reach
the rose 53 of them are schools of
tomorrow so they did great with the same
teachers not charter school system just
our our regular teachers just investing
in three things one communicating with
them regularly strongly second
motivating them saying that yes they can
they can retain kids that's not our aim
but we can and third giving the correct
rewards showing that yes sorry to take
this word from the states and a
different context yes we can we can
change education yes we can we can give
another kind of life we can give a
tomorrow for those kids thank you very
much
thank you very much Claudia for those of
you who are in the in other parts of the
country and world who thought you had
problems what an extraordinary what an
extraordinary story you've told what an
amazing achievement it's now my pleasure
to introduce to you Johan aura who is
the director of the finished National
Board of Education this is the national
agency subordinate to the Ministry of
Education of Finland he's responsible
for the Swedish education sector for
some of you who don't know finland has
two official languages Swedish and
Finnish and so he has a particular
challenge in his job of dealing with the
issues of multiculturalism and dual
language he has a background in
elementary as an elementary school
teacher in all subjects and a high
school teacher of physical education
he's also worked as a principal for six
years and as a superintendent for three
years at the finish board he's
responsible for the development of
education in the Swedish speaking
schools in Finland all through
pre-primary and basic education general
upper secondary education adult
education and basic education in the
arts it's a great pleasure to welcome
you here today
ladies and gentlemen in this
presentation I will speak about a
proposal concerning the renewal of Basic
Education in Finland as you all probably
know the Finnish education system
especially the comprehensive school is
known for its excellent learning
outcomes in the piece assessment 2000
2003 2006 finished 15 year olds have
been on the top in all studied domains
reading literacy mathematics Natural
Science and problem-solving knowledge
and skills the quality of learning is
high in all finished schools there are
very small differences between schools
in learning results practically all
students complete their compulsory
education even though we are doing well
we are planning a big renewal of basic
education in our country we know that
the world is changing and that the
results cannot stay high if we do if we
do not change too therefore the Ministry
of Education said a parliamentary
committee in spring 2009 to formulate a
proposal for the distribution of less
than ours the minimum number of hours to
be thought in each subject and the
general national objectives for the new
Basic Education Act the comedy submitted
its proposal in June 2010 in addition to
the proposal on the distribution of less
than ours the committee also made a
proposal for the renewal of basic
education as a whole the aim of the new
proposal is to develop basic education
and its objectives in a consistent way
by taking into consideration the present
strength of basic education and
development needs for the future the
finish in Finnish policymaking is based
on evidence and consultation of all
stakeholders therefore the starting
point committee comma day's work was
collecting evidence based on national
and international research and in decay
errors also stakeholders were hurt
including pupils who were interviewed as
mentioned earlier the Communists at
future objectives for the renewal of
basic education as a whole these
demonstrate the comedy's view of the
mission and integrity of basic education
in the future finished society I will
now outline the comedy's proposal
according to the four objectives of the
renewable namely to clarify and enhance
the mission and integrity of basic
education to ensure the high level of
knowledge and skills to strengthen and
the provision of individual support and
guidance and to clarify the principles
of providing basic education firstly the
mission and integrity of basic education
involves citizen skills needed in the
society and individual futures at the
same time they highlight deeper learning
learning goals and high order skills
citizen skills are tools which support
deeper learning and applied knowledge
they have been classified into five
groups thinking skills ways of working
and interaction craft and expressive
skills participation and initiative and
self-awareness and personal
responsibility in the legislation
legislation that will be next the next
step in the renewal process the citizen
skills will be defined and combined with
the objectives set for each
multidisciplinary subject group as well
as the subjects these comprise of the
assessment criteria will also be defined
the high level of skills and knowledge
provided by basic education should be
ensured also in the future this requires
that the goals of knowledge and skills
are defined at high level the citizens
knowledge and skills are strengthened
that the welfare and functionality of
the pupils and school communities are
taken care of and that their resources
are ensured the implementation of the
mission of Basic Education in a changing
operational environmental required
environment requires bringing together
the core contents of focusing on the
import
issues so that there is place for
practicing knowledge and skills secondly
the company proposes that the national
core curriculum for basic education
should consist of compulsory and
optional subjects these would be defined
as multidisciplinary subject groups and
different subjects as their components
according to the proposal that there
would be six different multidisciplinary
subject groups each a multidisciplinary
subject group and subject follows the
general national objectives for basic
education specific objectives that will
combine the general objectives and core
contents will be defined for each
multidisciplinary subject group taking
into account the present core content in
addition to grouping subjects the comedy
proposes to new school subjects ethics
and drama ethics to is to reinforce the
basic values of the finished society and
to enhance a dialogue amongst pupils
representing different worldviews the
objective for drama is to strengthen a
comprehensive approach to art education
in order to support the development of
the pupils identity and growth in a
versatile way the multidisciplinary
sublet groups art and crafts and health
and personal functionality will be
emphasized it has been proposed that the
minimum number of less than ours and the
number of optional lesson hours will be
increased in arts and crafts and
physical education in particular the
increased aims to give you with more
opportunities two different options in
these subjects one of the challenges in
Finland is that while
internationalization is a priority
priority and schools are internationally
active most pupils learn English as
their first foreign language this means
that too few pupils learn other
languages such as French German Russian
and Spanish the community proposes that
the objective for language education is
to strengthen the language skills in the
society diversify language programs and
introduce it earlier as
well as to ensure the position of second
national language the implementation of
foreign language education and studied
studies in the second national language
as well as the opportunity to choose
amongst them in an equitable manner will
be strengthened with national guidance
foreign language education and second
national language studies will be
diversified and introduced earlier than
today the education providers duty to
offer a diversified language program
will be specified the education provider
must offer at least three alternative
languages which one is the second
national language instruction in the
language must be provided if they're at
least 10 pupils who have chosen that
language thirdly the comedy emphasis is
that in order to gain a good educational
base to provide opportunities for
individual growth in a versatile way
develop knowledge based skills and be
successful successful as a learner the
pupils knowledge and skills must be
taken into account this includes
knowledge and skills acquired outside
the school each pupil must be provided
with guidance and support the support
they need the guidance should motivate
pupils to find and develop their own
strengths as well as be motivated by
their own learning the proposal aims to
enhance pupils freedom to choose
optional lesson hours in an equal and
equitable manner the number of optional
lessons are less than ours will be
increased significant significant ly in
grades 3 through 9 the increase aims to
strengthen the objectives set for the
multidisciplinary sublet groups as well
as integrate and deepen their content
also this aims to give pupils and
education providers more opportunities
for different options and flexible
solution as well as to increase the
motivation to study finally the camry
proposes that basic education will be
there developed as an integral whole by
combining the three dimensions
objectives contents and implementation
in a systematic way the guidance system
will similarly be developed to support
basic education as an integral whole
all the objectives for the skills and
competences and individual needs in the
society have been classified into five
groups thinking skills ways of working
and interacting craft and expressive
skills participation and in initiative
self-awareness and personal
responsibility these above-mentioned
skills named citizen skills will be
defined as part of the general national
objectives but a new basic education
degree they will be included in the
objectives of the multidisciplinary
subject groups and the objectives of
individual subjects the Cameron
underlines that the implementation of
the object is for basic education
requires a national and comprehensive
agreement of the aims of the reform
further a clarification of the
principles of implementation and support
for the education providers will be
necessary in order to implement the
renewal and provide instructions
according to the objectives thank
thank you so much Johann there's a
reason Johannes here finland has one of
the most successful urban education
systems in the world and i know people
will be beating down the door to find
you afterwards to have that conversation
just want to take a brief moment to
welcome Commissioner Jeannie mulgrave of
the city of New York Department of youth
and Community Development and we're so
delighted she's here and I'm just
warning her in advance I hope our
international delegates particularly
find her we have I would say the most
innovative Department of youth and
Community Development I want to say in
our nation but I'm going to go out on a
limb and say the globe she works very
closely with our department of education
and has pioneered programs in after
school at the school as well as in
community organizations which both
support the school day and encourage
students to develop socially and
emotionally the Gina you taught me
something thank you for being here and
of course to my students you're looking
for internships find her right away now
it's my pleasure to introduce our third
panelist mom to Ronnie auger walk who is
the director of education at the noodle
new delhi municipal council since May
2008 the new delhi municipal council
provides primary and senior secondary
education within New Delhi so mamta
really covers everything I'm not sure
how you do this job and I know you'll be
telling us very shortly a very
challenging and difficult job in which
she has been a tremendous innovator her
initiatives include the development of a
system wide processes for academic and
administrative bodies to improve
efficiency following external evaluation
of the public education system I know
our mayor would be delighted to talk to
you about those initiatives there are
many
similar ones that we're pursuing in New
York City miss a koala was previously
the deputy director of the National
Institute of open schooling the largest
open school in the world and she served
as a flight lieutenant in the indian air
force from nineteen ninety five to two
thousand one maybe that's why you can do
that job she received a master's of
science and organic chemistry from
Osmani ax university welcome
good morning my dear friends honorable
mayor of the New York City for inviting
me here I wish to thank him former mayor
president of the columbia university
president of New York global
incorporation dignitaries on the dials
academicians educators administrators
and my fellow participants it is indeed
my privilege and honor to address
gathering on an international forum I
have to initiate my conversation with
two confessions one a sincere apology to
miss Carla Stewart one of the organizers
who kept on persuading me to prepare a
very well-organized writer and I start
and I still decided that I shall speak
on the subject extempore as somehow i am
not used to a very organized right up on
any subject and secondly i sincerely
believe that each one of you present
here it's much more experienced much
more aware of the subject then what I am
I shall still express my views share my
personal experiences whatever I have
gathered on the subject and immensely
important one and that is education
success is very very subjective I shall
take a very personal example here after
doing my grade 12 that is senior
secondary and before graduating to a
graduate college I was not allowed to
continue my studies for two years and
the reason a lady from a marginalized
community it is not considered
appropriate to attend colleges
today I stand before all of you and I
feel this is what education do and that
is what education and power a person
education is a very very wide subject a
very very wide word which is differently
understood across the context be it
political society or anything I shall
restrict myself to what I understand
education is to be education is a way of
life or if I may say it is life itself
how do all individuals react to
different situations what is their
degree of taking responsibilities for
their own actions their article
standards moral values community
belongingness responsibility as a
citizen everything is about education
and this is the education which they
receive from their families community
society formal schooling system
surroundings Nations and so on however I
shall restrict myself to a meaning of
Education in the formal schooling system
context and that is that schools should
impact students in a manner or should
impart such education the children can
go out physically fit academically sound
emotionally well-balanced morally
correct professionally competing
responsible citizens I shall be covering
my topic broadly into very briefly
touching upon the way education system
is in India local approach and
challenges and two vital aspects where I
change the system and really saw a
measurable change in our education
system in India education is from
kindergarten to grade two air
kindergarten and nursery are semi
formalized and it is not really required
to go through a particular school class
12 class 12
are again primary is class 12 class 5
middle school is six to eight secondary
is nine grade 9 and 10 and senior
secondary is great 11 and 12 it is a
matter of Union as well as the state's
funding comes from federal state and
even private partnership you will be
surprised to know that by 2012 the
private education industry in india is
expected to be 75 billion US dollar 75
billion US dollar it's a huge number
because we are a country of billion-plus
population and our young population is
550 million now the things the changes
which i made i will only be
concentrating on those changes when I
took over I realized that most of my
clientele was from lower socioeconomic
background where T parents were not able
to be integrated in the learning process
of their children and I realized that
unless parents educators and
administrators decide that their goals
are common and their children are
required to achieve those goals in close
coordination nothing can be achieved so
I made it mandatory it was very very
difficult but I just persuaded and
addressed all the parents telling them a
lie I am repeating telling them a lie
that if they attend these mandatory
workshops on parenting it will be added
on to the grades of their children which
was untrue but believe me it worked
really hit work I I made all the parents
and teachers realize that their parents
are their children I am sorry are the
most important ones and
their goals are the shared ones I had
two very very aggressively consistently
and progressively made my teachers
understand my educators understand that
you might be more educated academically
more sound but it is parents who know
the children better because I do not
know how many children are there in a
class in United States but it is only
for few minutes even the best possible
teacher can pay undivided attention to a
child I had to make them understand that
even if parents disagree with educators
you have to take their view in
consideration I had to make my educators
understand that even if the child is not
performing see you will have to involve
parents you have to take them on board
and believe me it worked I had to have
and I personally had consistent
workshops for my teachers to change the
attitude believe me I am not too sure
how is it in United States but there I
literally had to tell my teachers that
please do not consider yourself
academically so superior than most of
the parents and if especially if they
are stay stay home parents they can
still be most valuable partners so that
is one thing which I have done and
believe me my result in past one year
the first year it went up by twelve
percent the second year it went by 16.4
percent that is one thing which I have
done secondly competency of the teachers
see in the competency of the teachers I
very clearly categorized that there are
three aspects attitude skill and
knowledge and I realized right in that
hierarchy that I had to primarily change
their attitude and then we graded our
teachers and we realized wherever the
schools were low performing there we
made a change in the teachers
that is and not the hundred percent
change we just transferred the teachers
who were the most performing ones and
made them work with some of the teachers
who were the low motivators are the
teachers who were not as motivated and
believe me it worked and primarily we
really really dedicated lot of
responsibility in our principal allowed
him to behave to control and to be
responsible for the particular school in
that local context that is whatever was
available with the school but with
greater responsibility with greater
transparency and with greater
accountability and I think these two
small changes primarily integration of
parents and when you integrate the
parents their emotional aspect children
may come from home which are broken they
come from single-parent homes they come
from homes where there is no support
available integrating those parents
locating those parents integrating them
in the formal education system and then
continuously increasing the competency
of my teachers and so much more in
attitude than the skill and knowledge
and I think it made a huge difference
thank you so much thank you
thank you so much mamta I'm sure that
for the principal's in the audience here
much of what you said resonated with
them the importance of engaging parents
and making sure that teachers understand
the value of parents in the education
process I think is something that every
education system in the world needs to
recognize and and struggles with finally
our last panelist before we open the
floor to questions is yen Yu Jing who is
the deputy director general of the
Shanghai Municipal Education Commission
currently that job entails a quite a
complicated set of responsibilities he
has done this job since 1980 in Shanghai
but he comes with an extraordinary set
of credentials and also educational
experience in the field mr. ian has
worked in the divisions for basic
education and social development for the
pudong new area of Shanghai he also
serves as a national school inspector
and is a member of an expert group on
curriculum reform for the Ministry of
Education his vice chair of the Shanghai
Education Council and holds professional
professorships in each china normal
university and shanghai normal
university he was formerly a high school
senior teacher and he studied Chinese
language and education management at the
College of educational management in
east china normal university and holds a
bachelor's degree in a graduate degree
in chinese language it is a great
pleasure to welcome you to New York City
into this conference today thank you
Jinjin the truth serum go enjoy it all
right nachiketa good morning well I I'm
from Tasha Toni Elias and in my 20 years
from Gaza in Shanghai I'm from Shanghai
I'm Bree honor to be here I will tell
you all about a station in Shanghai song
hi to Charlie Edgington your shanghai
good stranger kanji is facing many
changes Eastern Allegiant you want a mom
julia and a very very intensive she
commissioned for teaching methods just
changing the ways of knowledge
production and stimulation to label I
can internally some sanity chosen gender
in the 1990s Sean Shanghai is
impermanent dreamed a patent leather
education generation joy mg containment
Giada Kaiser we have to change a
dramatically mean DiGiorgio by the had
to change as well see that right now the
citizen in Georgia has height
requirement for the high quality citizen
education it has been demonstrated far
time that you don't I see the trends for
change in the last 20 years the
population of urban are you in the urban
area has to be from million people to 10
million people due to the population
increase chi tung choi education
environment change require us to do to
change to take out any active majors fun
perspectives your comment very much
believe between our city and people so
how to make education walking through
what the fan is an
excellence oh you couldn't go to mode
yeah yummy Joe you perform education
basic education in the turn of the
century we have implemented the basic
educational change in Shanghai because
we find our curriculum reform it's not
your call what we have to consider that
people reality futures I'm a finder
right now we have to develop advantage
you have to overcome so coming or our
education or the suit and facing the
futures you owe me unlike United States
and European country oh we have a solid
knowledge John so we have a lot of
learning experiences by right now this
kind of students use its we encourage
creativity and a week in exploration and
critical thinking therefore our new
curriculum reform we haven't emphasized
not only on the basic knowledge we have
not only have a basic type of the
Caribbean and also we have a three type
of the curriculum basic type and
expansion ties and research type the
expansion type of Caribbean they have is
a map develop their potentials in using
codes and the research type of
curriculum to lead students fast you to
find out the questions Jews are too
young she's having so many pills yet you
to research and the cooperating are the
awareness for the pseudonym that is an
elective course with limited access for
students curtain so wish that I chicken
noodle so as this as a base for students
in the building to reach the base
extender
we have a unified standard the Shanghai
curriculum reform is the standard is the
bottom line quality many students and
have a profit effort to reach certain
standard we have strictly true
eliminated gap between students we have
to run good schools Chico joy yeah and
to enhance the education quality we have
to run this course because the certain
factors I reach our geographic
difference and the history historical
and traditional are factors there was
different gap in turned up the education
quality specially Shanghai as facing
many urban and rural different system so
the high quality a ruler urban schools
has many resources however in school in
the rural area that they have enough
resources I thought I said shanghai in
the last 20 do by women shanghai in quiz
a 29 million people therefore we have
another new students so those new
population increase our population
accounted for seventy percent of our new
students will idea therefore in our new
city entire city the outsider as a
counter for the military mandatories
forty-eight percent of our entire
educational population George therefore
we have to enhance the education quality
in a rural suburban schools how short
time we have to thats employer good
principle to be no schools you will
cause you're done because good principle
can swing out which are good students
your g1 and the punishment and the
leading all those school curricula notes
and a relationship from
this is the shield to enhance the school
quality cuzco oh gee Tom Perrotta soy
sauce you can do time we can group to
settle all of kneeling a good school and
to manage those schools with lower
quality secondly and we have to
implement the school dedicated
administration in 2002 we have
implemented delegation administration
when for those schools with lower
quality dedicated to a high quality
school for two doses so those tetas can
estimate an appreciation joy already
breaks through our the current show
coming and obstacles and we integrate
all those resource of course I regions
to achieve such a result since you can
judge the pairings our program between
the city and the county school districts
in Shanghai we have 18 districts we so
far we have a nice rural county school
districts of hair with a nice City tea
trees changing ideas are helping each
other implement reforms and innovative
ideas to achieve mutual beneficial
manifesto so judge the city education
system to a education system in a rural
area sir Julian and number three improve
the teaching and the searching system
Joe finally the Congo yeah my cosmo
sponsor speaking adheres you want to
enhance teaching you have to have a well
established system to allow the
specialized their professional bodies to
impossible other change so as a
government we to help the research and
the teaching opus teaching and the
research office is a body through
purchases of governments and educational
solutions to provide guidance on
teaching in China the teaching and
research assistants
has been around for 61 years he has
played an important part in ensuring the
quality passenger education in China
that the majors are were taken to follow
number one it's to set up the teachings
and the research in networks of a
three-level number to emphasize on
customize the teaching and the research
a systems for each individual schools so
that each teachers can participate in
their own teaching and research always
to focus on the individual needs of
every school and to reformat the
teachings the actor each individual
school where they are natural so that
you the office is supporting each school
and each class in the school popular to
you and the so data to improve the level
of teaching number three is a church in
the process of teaching and the research
of worker now we set up city wipe system
we want to provide the waste to send our
message of teaching and research content
establish an internet based teaching and
the researcher communications judge
hunter and we want to a twins our a
teacher you Phantom because we want to
change the best practices of teachers
and number four we under strengthen the
calculation for teachers first we'll
give a better continued education for
all teachers what we require a be
teachers has to go through 240 hours or
training programs 85 years respectively
which fifty percent shall be in school
number 220 program for teachers in the
rural areas OD establish a citywide
education resources of alliances with
attractive that's a professional service
and the presser teachers from the Prime
Minister and the secondary school to
form and teacher Alliance and the club
provide a guidance for Shanghai
education system
thank you so much again that's an
extraordinary presentation you've made I
know your responsibilities for almost 10
million students in the Shanghai
metropolitan area is something that even
those of us in New York who think we
have a big challenge which with our 1.1
million public school students can
appreciate what you have to deal with I
think the recommendations you make were
extremely helpful to everybody in the
room I'm going to ask audience members
who are interested in addressing our
panelists to come up to the microphones
to ask them their questions and I'll
call on you and I just request that you
have a question as opposed to making an
editorial comment although I know that
since we are a group of educators here I
do expect there to be some breaking of
the rules and some comments so i won't i
won't take the chairs prerogative to ask
my question since we have members of the
audience who are interested in asking
questions but i might jump in and do
that in a couple of minutes why don't we
start with you and please identify
yourself your name and your profession
and what country you're from hello my
name is Richard Reynolds I'm from the
School of International and public
affairs and I'm from Massachusetts the
United States the former New York City
Teaching Fellow and when I taught
English in the Bronx for two years I
witnessed firsthand the effects of
parental involvement on education in
fact ets and 2007 cited lack of parent
involvement as the biggest factor
affecting public education in this
country actually recently in Detroit
they've had they've taken measures to
put forth in incentives based program to
increase parental involvement other
states have talked about mandates this
is particularly directed towards mamta
what measures are
taken in your country to increase
parental involvement and how do you
measure how do you track the progress
and it's direct impact on the lives of
children student and student academic
achievement mamta to please start and
then Claudia also please respond and
then we'll take the next question you
want me to respond when we started with
the project of integrating parents we
started with certain pilot schools we
did not go ahead straight away what did
we do is we made certain things
mandatory that parents teacher
interaction we made it mandatory certain
times in some of the schools it wasn't
mandatory and it was not at regular
intervals then we always inform our
parents when was going to be the
interaction so much well in advance when
other than informing them that when is
suppose we told them that the
interaction is going to the fifth
fifteenth of next month we also either
ways either the teacher personally spoke
to the period send them the mail
wherever was the possibility that the
areas where what are the areas which
they are going to discuss with the
parents if it was about Addie behavioral
aspect if it was about academic progress
if if it was about discipline in the
class it was about any learning
difficulty similarly while deciding
everything whether it was eligibility
age for a child to go to school it was
the learning aids which were to be used
in the school it was about anything
parents were taken on board when we
started this in the five schools
initially we realize that all of a
sudden the result started going better
that there was more attendance rate
children who were not even completing
their homework they were doing their
homework so lot of small
little things there were 50 measurable
parameters attendance rate they are
doing homework they're difficult
subjects such as mathematics maybe
sciences how did they perform to that
and then we realized that these five
schools have become better and I just
want to tell you that which I could not
cover in my speech we have got our
schools accredited by a quality Council
of India it is a national agency for
accreditation we realize these were the
first five schools which were accredited
and the accreditation parameters are
absolutely measurable 50 parameters for
example what is the percentage of result
what is the percentage of attendance so
this is how we did it we don't have time
for follow-up unfortunately because
there's just too many questions but I
would like Claudia to address that
really well parental involvement is an
issue in Brazil because most parents
have less years of schooling than their
kids we did research on that in 2008 and
we discovered that they over evaluated
they evaluate very favorably the schools
of their kids although quality is really
an issue so what we did in Rio very
quickly in one year and 10 months we
first we prepared a booklet on how to be
a great mom you know because we have
single families and how to be a great
mom in what relates to school it was
rehired summaries depict mom and not dad
yes yes we did different things with
that but with moms a specific booklet
written by journalists that know the
language of classes d and e moms and and
it was very helpful with meetings to
read to illiterate parents what to to do
because we were
establishing homework homework was not a
practice anymore in Rio so reestablish
homework we wanted parents to be able to
make sure that kids have the proper
setting for that and school attendance
and so on second there is something in
rhe in Brazil that is called both of
Familia which means it is as if a
scholarship that the family received
based on school attendance but the
conditionalities were very low so we
enforced conditionalities and if a kid
doesn't ago ninety percent of classes in
a by master the kid loses this
scholarship which is means for and then
he must he can receive it again if he
continued go but if the parent doesn't
go to meetings either one of the parents
also they lose this kind of cost collar
ship for two months in addition to that
we created a school of pair for parents
space specifically for early childhood
we want to make sure that even parents
that don't say and send kids to early
childhood centers that they get the
proper orientation the proper guidance
on how to nourish nourish nourish and
nurture babies so and they receive even
books to read to their kids even if they
are illiterate they they are taught how
to deal with books for kids and last but
not least just one final thing with the
schools of tomorrow with those violent
areas three mothers work in each school
just to be a pacifier present the
pacification presence during recess to
avoid bowling to escalate to something
even more violent
I'm going to take the next question
thank you very much that was both of you
very helpful response yeah Thank You
Tata Levinson from the CEPA school here
at Columbia from California there's been
many references to the quick changes
that are occurring in the world both in
the workplace as well as socially and so
I'm wondering what what kind of reforms
you do in regards to making sure that
that school systems remain relevant and
effective in meeting these changes both
in in meeting the current change the
current workplace and social needs now
but also changes that allow it to adapt
quickly as changes have become ok so
that's more of a in a way a management
question too about how do you adopt
adapt rather quickly to change I'm going
to ask Johan and yin to respond to that
question thank you yes school systems
changed very slowly which means that you
can't actually do anything fast so so
the things that we we know today and the
things we are changing today there will
be in four or five years there will be
reality in the schools so I don't
actually have an a good answer how we
can it can we maybe because your system
works so well you don't worry as much
about changes the rest of us and I think
that's one of the secrets as well we
don't change too much all the time and
too fast it's an important point yen
cheers to you yeah duh a school
assistant change is a very slow and
difficult but you if you want to make a
change you have the changing teacher so
just as a mother I'm indicated in my
speech changed the advantage of a
Chinese education she pounds the weight
for coal is to trying to provide the
student with basic education but we
don't provide a critical thing
all students so that's reason when we
make a reform we are to make a
curriculum reform but the reform has to
be carried out by teachers therefore we
have making you a substantial changes
among teachers are required in recent
survey twenty-six percent of students
feel the changes we made our supporters
that means a seventy-four percent of
students have them about the changes we
implemented you pay I feel that even
though only twenty-six percent of
students about the manufacturer you know
just like I say that that we emphasize
on the researcher security in innovative
career carranza I feel that Eddie's is
apocrypha so much that we insist i feel
that eventually majority of students at
work feel the benefits thank you I'm
gonna call on Michelle Cahill who is was
part of the mayor's reforms in the first
administration at the Department of it
and the creator of the small high
schools in New York a highly successful
extraordinary program and who's here as
part of our conference today and I know
you have a question I have a quick
question from particularly directed to
miss cost and an innovation that you
mentioned that I think is really
intriguing that in your schools of
tomorrow in those most challenged
neighborhoods you focus on science and
yet you talked about the students being
like proportion of them being illiterate
and our president Obama has been talking
about what we call stem science
technology engineering and math as a
driver of reform I wondered how you got
to that and then how'd it work out going
okay and let me be quick we first we
separated the kids that were illiterate
we trained our teachers very quickly and
prepare them to reoffer 'but eyes those
kids so those kids were sent to a
different track
there it was thirteen fourteen percent
of the kids on those grades four fifths
and six so it was an issue but it was
something that we can address separately
the science approach was related to
three things first to make going to
school fun every day interesting if you
teach science the correct way I'm
talking about elementary school and
middle school it it's amazing we have in
the schools of tomorrow we ask the kids
what do you dream to become when you
grow up because we don't want them to
dream to become drug dealers so most of
them say we want to be soccer players
that's Brazil but growingly they they
say I want to become a scientist I want
to become an engineer I don't know if
they will but that they think something
out of their peculiar box and so it was
really something that changed that
school attendance is increased and they
are having fun and on the other hand it
work it deals with developing an
investigative mind you know and that
helps with Portuguese and mass as well
thank you i'm going to ask our last two
questioners to just quickly articulate
the questions and then everybody will
get one last chance to respond to either
of these questions Susan Crawford member
of the two million parent hawker sea of
New York City and out of my experiences
with my dyslexic kids I form something
called the right to read project and
miss Carson has just answered what was
done in in the schools of tomorrow so
that's covered but because there's a
cross section of languages here I'm
especially interested to know what you
do in your each of your country's
dyslexia effects twenty percent of the
plot
elation across the world but it affects
different languages differently its
worst it's the worst in English so I'm
just curious to know how you address
okay David Allen from an organization
called New Jersey seeds which works with
low-income students here high-achieving
low-income students my questions for
Miss Costin but first I just want to say
to mr. hora I was just deeply inspired
by the reform and fiddling on and the
emphasis on ethics and acting I think
that's was really exciting this costume
my questions for you the issue of
performance incentives for teachers is
very controversial here so I was just
wondering if you could speak a little
bit about the reforms and how it worked
and what you did the incentives issue
applies to number of the cities we've
talked about so I'm going to take this
last question also and then everybody
can pick which question they want to
answer thank you my name is Vivian Lucia
time the wise mayor of the city of
Luxembourg but I am also graduated in
nurse education science my question is
because you told the fourth of you about
things which should change the school
system things these are not only in
relation with knowledge in my city we
create a communal program action program
to put in at work all the politics
concerning children and the most
difficult was and still is to in Globe
the school's the primary schools in this
networking we try to tell the teachers
that it's not only knowledge but we said
in French savoir faire le savoir vivre
would make knowledge of being knowledge
of of doing that it's also part of the
education system of the school system
but it's very difficult you were talking
about parents about arts about theater
about hurls about all these things do
you are you also the same meaning have
you also the same meaning that
education it's in fact not only school
it's also the things around the schools
and the state school in the new school
system should open more and include the
other politics inside thank thank you
very much for your question we're going
to begin with yen and everybody will
take very brief responses to any of
those three questions pick one and so
the question when you you change your
windows that when this gentleman asked
about your tongue gender to you that how
was what teach parents are play a role
in case education we are facing to kinda
of a parent's a one responsible parents
who d-day she's fun the family the life
is a story to learning of a parent such
as a educator we have to communicate to
the parents and to how other parents to
a queer the environmental where students
can learn the other is a the overbearing
parents dispenser the thomson they are
cared you know this for you any minute
listen you for your parents to kids will
play piano to enter to learn paintings
we have a lot of overbearing parents of
you we have to tell them please get them
a bring Joey since education times your
leader needs to focus on the morality of
human being ok we emphasize too though
Bob Arum Aaron become this is a my
corner of you so the thought you can I
don't know whether oh wait I urging you
share what to me I feel that your
education is a not only combined in
school but also reach to parents thank
you
I will answer to the question of wise
mayor of Luxembourg yes I completely
agree that schools are not only about a
CAD makes so I am sure as everywhere is
even in my country everything be it
theater arts music vocal non-vocal
sports everything is part of the
curriculum which is designed it is part
of the lesson plans it is part of what
whatever is to be covered in the entire
annual year the second second aspect is
how do we do it in my country since most
of the children come from extremely
lower socioeconomic background
especially in public schools the case is
not so in the private schools we have
launched a program known luck chef which
in my language means target where
wherever the children are extraordinary
in whatever they are extraordinary it
can be that they are extraordinary in
taking a technical subject they are
extraordinary in playing violin or
anything we take care of them this is a
there is an ability section which we in
our language called luck sure that is
target we take care of everything from
after grade 12 their counseling to their
teaching to their see training and in
every financial aspect every every kind
of aspect is taken care by us so that is
there are where we are not able to
integrate as a state we take care of
everything thank you Johan in Korea
quickly okay I'm trying to be quick
Howie I'm going to answer the question
how we deal with the students who have
dyslexia with in Finland we start with
early intervention which means we test
all the students in before they start
school actually and in the grade in the
first grade so we try to find out if
they have some kind of problems and if
they do have they will get individual
support in every school we have a
special education teacher who can give
that to the student and we also have
personal assistance which means that
there could be in the classroom at the
same time with the
teacher a coke teacher who will take
care of these kids who have special
needs thank you ok so I'll answer the
performance incentives you know there I
don't know how is it in in in New York
and other cities in the States but there
are lots of charming projects that
surround schools people who offer
interesting projects or focus on school
buildings wonderful buildings with
serving bowls and so on and school is
about learning so the school must open
itself too many things but it is about
learning and if kids don't learn to read
right to to learn computing mathematics
I mean they won't be good citizens
because they won't read the papers they
won't make their own decisions so first
thing we evaluate schools based on kids
learning and we decided not to compare
schools but to set targets for schools
to be better than themselves so to
improve learning compared to their past
so that we don't compare a school in a
violent slum with a school in
middle-class neighborhood and so each
each school signed a contract a kind of
contract that has no necessarily legal
binding but it is Ali a contract and
based on that contract all the team all
the members of the team that are not
that were not absent that year that
school year they receive a prize in
money if they reach that target that
dark are the money they received is
enhanced if they work in a school of
tomorrow but it's an important money for
them
it builds on on team being a team player
so it's not that the fifth grade teacher
receivers and not the fourth grade the
the requirement to receive the prize is
kids improvement and not being absent
more than five times that school year
even on legal grounds if the mother had
a baby that year it's very happy she
will receive the whole salary but not
the price the prices for the teachers
that you know we same / in Brazil who
held the piano that year who had the
burden to work extra hours because the
other words were not present that's how
our system works thank you very much
what an extraordinary panel you've all
been amazing and we're delighted that
you could join us this morning